[Music]
this morning we're hearing the dramatic
story of an afghan interpreter who
served alongside the u.s military but is
now struggling to get a visa to escape
to the united states our cbs news
investigative unit spoke with the man
who is in hiding and also with a u.s
marine who saw combat alongside this
translator
senior investigative correspondent
katherine harris reports now on the man
and his family and how they fear they
could soon be killed
he's an incredibly honorable man who who
served our country at great peril to his
own life former marine mike donahue is
talking about the afghan translator who
embedded with his unit in 2009 who will
call sherzod for security reasons how
much time does sherzod and his family
have could be hours could be days
i'm just hoping he makes it back this is
one of his letters of appreciation
documents reviewed by cbs news suggest
sherzod applied for a special immigrant
visa as early as 2016.
donahue told us the process was botched
and he resubmitted sherzod's papers
along with multiple commendations from
the u.s military every moment i'm in
danger we reached sherzod where he's
hiding in a safe house in afghanistan
that's littered with garbage and filth
we agreed to blur his face every moment
i feel taliban will find out and you
know they will kill us
[Applause]
after nearly escaping last month's
suicide bombing at the kabul airport
sherzod fled the city with his wife and
children i'm scared about my family kids
that's it when shirzad told us the
taliban are hunting translators his
feelings overtook him please expedite
our our process
exploit our process you know
we are almost getting killed man
watching that video is an extremely
emotional thing i mean god what did we
do to these people what did we do we
left them we abandoned them a state
department spokesperson would not
address sherzod's case but told cbs news
they are processing special immigrant
visas at an accelerated rate and will
continue their relentless efforts to
help if you're relentless you look at
this documentation and you say
why is he still there
figure it out and that's what it's going
to take is a leader in the state
department or in our government to just
say figure it out if we as the most
powerful country in the world don't
honor our word what good is it as night
fell in afghanistan and the internet
connection faded shirzod told us he
still hasn't lost faith in his american
friends for right now
the biggest hope and my dream has been
in the
[Music]
united states
i am dreaming man
and sharzod told us he's taking the risk
of talking to the media because he has
only two options one get his message out
and get to the us or two face the very
real prospect that he and his family
will be killed by the taliban gail
god catherine this is so tough to see
2016 he filed i think he's right when he
says figure it out we're the united
states of america we can do this thank
you catherine thank you very much